(sad music)
- [Officer] I know this is hard,
but I need to ask you some questions
about what happened.
- He tied my hands.
He said if I screamed, he'd kill me.
- No signs of forced entry.
Doors and windows were locked.
No DNA.
Not a single neighbor
saw or heard a thing.
- He brought a blindfold
but nothing to tie her with.
Would a shoelace even hold her?
- You think Marie made up the attack?
- I'm pretty positive that it happened.
- Pretty positive or positive?
- They just kept asking
me the same question.
"How come your story doesn't add up?"
I wanted to go home.
- I don't have a victim here.
It's bogus.
She made it up.
(intense music)
- [Reporter] We are on the
scene of a violent attack.
Police say a masked assailant broke in
while the victim was sleeping.
- He said, "You need to be
more protective of yourself."
(camera flash clicking)
- Black mask.
Bindings.
Early morning attacks.
- I think he's done this before.
(gun firing)
- Aurora.
18 months ago.
Intruder.
Black mask, backpack,
tied her up, took photos.
To date, he's not been caught.
(intense music)
- You see the pattern.
There's a rape.
New evidence, new leads,
and then one by one they
dry up until he hits again.
- This one we're figuring out on our own.
(intense music)
- What if he knows stations
don't talk to each other?
As long as he only hits once in each town.
- You could have detectives
from eight different departments
investigating eight identical rapes
with no clue they're all
chasing the same guy.
- Victims are all over the map.
Old, young, different races.
So he doesn't have a type.
- Sure he does, women who live alone.
- [Officer] This guy is out there
preying on the most
vulnerable women he can find.
Where is the outrage?
(intense music)
This is not something people get over.
This is something they
carry with them forever.
(intense music)
- Even with people that you can trust,
if the truth is inconvenient,
they don't believe it.